est-ce que tu en as marre qu'on te
présente comme l'homme idéal oui si tu
n'avais pas été astronaute est-ce que tu
serais resté pilote de
ligne sans doute est-ce que ça sent bon
dans l'ISS non est-ce que tu es déjà
tombé malade dans l'espace non et
l'astrologie est-ce que tu y crois pas
du tout marcher sur la lune est-ce que
c'est un objectif oui l'argent fait-il
le bonheur non est-ce que tu es
optimiste pour l'avenir oui tu étais bon
en art plastique à l'école non on a
trouvé une faille ça t'angoisse le temps
qui passe pas encore être astronaute et
avoir une famille est-ce que c'est
compatible non 6 mois à bord de l'ISS
est-ce que ça te semblait long non tu
prends des stagiaires avec toi dans
l'ISS non être astronaute et écolo
est-ce que c'est possible oui est-ce que
le chinois c'est plus dur à apprendre
que le Russe oui le monts-michel c'est
en Normandie oui on ira sur Mars un jour
oui et dernière question un chinois sur
la lune est-ce que c'est possible un
jour oui et j'ai j'ai j'ai puuisé toutes
les questions